I know you will still love me the same  ed Sheeran made his return to the stage  and he appears to have a new scrape on  his face that's hard not to notice I  look at every day on Wednesday the  thinking out loud singer performed at a  fundraiser dinner for East Anglia's  children's hospital in London and took  the moment to joke about his new star  explaining to the audience he got his  face cut open according to BBC News  Princess Beatrice accidentally sliced  Sheeran with a swoosh while trying  tonight James Blunt at a party the 25  year old singer reportedly needed 25  stitches after the incident  this March Sharon's first show since he  announced last December he will be going  on a social media silence and traveling  the world so does this mean Sheeran is  back in the spotlight for good  you